foreign
yes we have one of the world's most
productive cosmologists in the house
right now and we've got questions for
him David spurgle are you ready for
these yes absolutely I
I thought you were talking about me and
being the most accomplished uh but
anyway okay yeah they're cosmetologist
yes cosmetologist that's exactly what we
were talking about yeah exactly uh Kyla
Speakman uh from patreon Kyla Speakman
don't have a location I genuinely only
have a patreon to subscribe to you and
one other also space related Creator
thank you for taking my question in the
ever expanding Universe there seems to
be a decrease in the amount of visible
matter while an increase in Dark Matter
dark gravity could it be that as visible
matter is pulled into black holes dark
matter is released via Hawking radiation
also when a black hole dies what happens
to said Hawking radiation
[Music]
um
okay lots of interesting questions there
so first um so that the total amount of
visible matter
or matter made of atoms electrons things
is about constant but the volume of
universe keeps growing bigger as the
universe expands
so the the total number of atoms in the
visible Universe stays constant but it
gets bigger so that dilutes it so it's
the density that's dropping
wait David are we not losing are we not
losing matter beyond our Horizon uh as
it expands it's still there we're not
seeing it no it's still there okay fine
and you know dark matter
and atoms ordinary matter behaves
similarly they both can fall in black
holes they but they're you know not that
much falls into black holes it's a small
fraction
you know
uh well below a percent
um
dark energy or sometimes called vacuum
energy on the other hand
is energy associated with empty space
so as the universe expands and there's
more and more space there's more and
more vacuum energy
so when the universe was a billion years
old vacuum energy wasn't that important
today it's the dominant form of energy
it's about 70 percent of the energy
density of the universe is in this
energy associated with empty space today
in 10 billion years it will be like 90
in 20 billion years it'll be like 99
so the dark matter and ordinary matter
are
just getting diluted as space expands
and the vacuum energy becomes more
important
so Paul what he just said is we're all
going to die
well we're all gonna die regardless of
whether the universe is expanding you're
probably not going to notice the
expansion of the universe that much for
another billion years but you know
you're probably not going to make a
billion you know I'm sorry no I don't
care damn
I've been taking good care of myself I'm
eating right
yeah we're a seat belt man you ruin
everything David I'll tell you all right
now the radiation is um actually
uh
for a black massive black holes walking
radiation is a very small effect it will
take trillions and trillions in years
for the sort of black holes that we
detect to produce a significant amount
of walking radiation and the Hawking
radiation is mostly in the form of
radiation not matter Paul give me
another sure Richard Hart here from Elk
Grove California I've seen a lot of news
recently regarding tired light what
exactly is it and how does it impact the
way we view the age of the universe
[Music]
um
so the idea behind tire and Light
and it's not an idea that seems
consistent with the universe as we
observe it is that as light travels to
us it loses energy
so the red shifting effect that we're
seeing as we look at distant galaxies is
not due to the expansion of the universe
but of light losing energy as it travels
in in the tired light hypothesis yeah in
the tardeline hypothesis now
right now we have many different ways of
testing
the expanding Universe model the
expanding Universe model says the
universe
distant objects not only should be
redshifted they should have lower
surface brightness
uh time itself gets stretched so when we
look at a supernova explosion for
example when we look at one nearby it
takes 50 days for the Supernova to drop
in brightness by Factor two but because
time gets stretched the same way like
gets stretched what we observe is if we
look at a distant one when the universe
was half its present size it takes a
hundred days even more distance one it
takes 150 days
so we're not seeing
just talk like getting red shifted we're
seeing time getting stretched we're
seeing the behavior of the stretching of
space
and as we look further back in time we
look at the microwave background we see
that the Universe was much harder
and we can test our expanding Universe
model in multiple ways so for example we
can predict the density of atoms
from the properties what we see in the
microwave background how sound waves
behave in the early universe
we could also predict the density of
atoms from the amount of deuterium
produced in the first three minutes of
the Big Bang
both those techniques predict it with an
uncertainty of only a few percent
and they agree remarkably well and we
have many many tests like that that test
the consistency of the expanding
Universal model so we're not entirely
reliant on one interpretation of the
redshift now we've got many cross checks
on it so we can measure the temperature
of the microwave Background by seeing
how it affects
gas clouds at high red shift and we can
see
at redshift one when the universe was
half its present size the temperature
was double
and at redshift three it was four times
as high so we can test this in many
different ways and get a consistent
picture consistent with the universe
that's 13.8 billion years old
in other words Paul you can't make this
stuff up it's two well it's funny
because I thought David was it just
sounds like he was winging it it was
very big he was very vague he had no
specifics I'm like this guy's just what
up now no but so David was was there
some recent paper about so there was a
recent paper claiming a much older age
for the universe based on an analysis of
colors of galaxies
and that analysis
um
rested on a lot of questionable
assumptions
so Paul that's a scientist's way of
saying he was
dog poop it's dog poop
[Music]
hey Neil happy sweet 16. what you this
is your 16th book coming out the one
that we started working on together two
years ago
this yeah
well thank you yes it's my 16th book
practically forgot about because I've
been very busy and I guess it's coming
out a month well it's my first book so
oh sorry we gotta do something sorry so
I should be more excited that okay
absolutely
I met you guys but I think this is your
best one yet
so but but is it is it but is it still
intriguing or
equally implicating this relative to
other papers that even you've written
yeah no
can I get the person's name can we get
the odd note I think they work uh very
quick to issue press releases
that emphasize an interpretation that
was uh questionable right why would you
do why would you do that knowing that
you're going to get called on it I mean
they got to know that there are people
out there like the two of you and me who
could call them on this well yeah
seriously some people think there's no
such thing as bad press
yeah
um no look we are seeing in the James
Webb data uh when we look at the early
galaxies things we don't understand
these are these galaxies that were in
the Dark Ages these are galaxies emerge
as we emerge from the Dark Ages yeah and
um these are galaxies that turn out to
be often uh brighter than many people
expected
um my own interpretation is the first
generation of stars were primarily very
massive stars
that you know the first stars were not
stars like our sun but SARS 10 50 times
the mass of our sun
um more like some of the brightest stars
we see in the night sky
and that would confound a traditional
interpretation of where those galaxies
of what the galaxies are doing as as
found by James Webb okay so I think
people start very reasonably by assuming
that the stars in the distant Galaxy
have the same distribution of very
massive stars and stars like the sun as
our galaxy but I
um and then if you start with that
assumption you read some surprising
conclusions and my feeling is the right
thing to do is question that assumption
and that probably are just uh primarily
supermassive Stars forming at high red
shift Paul David is no fun at a party
you know you try to put out a cool idea
and then he just rationalizes it away
you know well it's like you're standing
there and it's like this is great punch
and David's like is it
you say it's Kettle One vodka I say it's
uh Smirnoff you kind of think you know
how do you know they didn't uh you know
a lot of bars keep the good bottles and
they fill it with the cheap stuff there
you go and then they still put it on the
top shelf right if I'm gonna go buy a
car I'm taking David with me I am taking
David with me he's my guy let's slip in
one more question one more question
David Robertson good day from Aubrey
Australia Down Under
David has anyone found anomalies in the
cosmic microwave background radiation
I'm told it's basically the same in any
direction the stuff we can see in One
Direction can't see the stuff we can see
in the opposite direction we can't be in
the middle we are not that special wow
that's okay how much larger is are you
ready for yourself exactly it's like
someone wasn't hugged as a child
we love you David
uh David Robertson we love you okay we
can't we can't be in the middle we are
not we're not that special how much
larger is our universe or is it just a
really weird shape
so there's a lot of interesting
questions there
um it appears that the universe is large
and very uniform
we can have tried to measure the shape
or effectively the size of the universe
and all we can say at this point is we
have a lower bound that the size of the
universe the size if you went in One
Direction and you would come back on
yourself so imagine going around a donut
where you come around after we started
um that size of the donut if that's the
shape of the universe must be larger
than what we could see so it's at least
26 billion light years across so we
don't know whether the universe is
infinite or finite
but if it's finite is it is really big
so we live in a big universe
and we live as David noted in a universe
that's nearly uniform
and we see the same pattern of
fluctuations roughly in the different
directions and the fluctuations don't
seem to have anomalies they seem to be
drawn from kind of a bell curve
distribution that we call a gaussian
um and it the statistical properties of
the fluctuations are
incredibly simple so we detected at this
point millions of independent points of
fluctuations
and the universe turns out to be so
simple that they can describe the
properties of those fluctuations by two
numbers the amplitude of the
fluctuations and how they vary with
scale and that completely characterizes
it so it's a so that means you're not
finding interesting weird things deep
buried in the cosmic microwave
background weren't there some people who
were looking for that to see lots of
people if there was like a a a a
parallel universe bumping into it
whether one One Direction was the mirror
image of it in another Direction
so people look for those
collisions of other universes they look
for like are there high peaks in fact I
was one of the people who did this right
are there high peaks are the
fluctuations
are The Valleys different from the Hills
and it just every time we look for
something
the universe just disappoints us and
just stays simple and it isn't revealing
are you still looking for like there's a
supposedly a signal that for a brief
period after the there was a like a fast
expansion of the universe right after
the big business yeah so this is a idea
of a theory called inflation that
predicts this really rapid expansion it
helps explain why the universe can look
so similar on two different sides
um and it predicts the pattern of
temperature fluctuations we see so it's
been successful and just to be clear
David correct me if I'm wrong the
temperature of the universe in One
Direction
in the early Universe compared with a
whole other direction is more uniform
than the temperature variation in the
room I'm sitting in
uh depends on the room but almost
certainly unless you're in a special
room
yes he's in a special hermetically
sealed room no I got an air conditioner
over there
over there right you got air
conditioning on you it's definitely
bigger fluctuations
yeah so now the fluctuations are are
tiny and to give it a sense of what we
are trying to do is astronomers is this
inflation Theory this period of very
rapid expansion predicts that there
should be these very long wavelength
gravitational waves that were produced
in the Big Bang during this period of
inflation
we haven't detected them yet but they
protect a very distinctive signal in the
pattern of polarization
and as we speak we're I just got some
pictures last night of uh our site in
Chile where we're building a radio
telescope 17 000 feet above sea level
and it's optimized to look for these
signals because we want to test this
idea of inflation and see if we can find
uh the gravitational wave signal
oh my God you guys just like to spend
money don't you all right we got to end
it there but we have a zillion cosmology
question Dave we'll have to bring it
back uh possibly even when you finally
submit the report uh to Congress or to
NASA for your studies in UAP uh but
thank you for your leadership there and
it's been a delight and an honor and a
privilege to count you as my friend and
colleague over these many decades that
we've been working always a pleasure
talking yeah yeah Paul all right dude uh
good to have you there thanks all right
this has been a a quick Cosmic queries
on the cosmology of this universe with
David Sparkle and my co-host there is
Paul Mercurio as always keep looking up
foreign
[Music]